et on s'en va directement dans les
boîtes de monsieur drapeau la collection
des archives personnelles de l'ancien
maire jean drapeau est grandiose
elle occupe 700 boîtes dans les voûtes
de la ville de montréal ou s'adonnent
152 mètres de documents comme fonds
privés c'est le fond le plus gros qu'on
a ici
ils avaient tous gardé monsieur drapeau
au conserver tous et des fois même en
plusieurs exemplaires
jean drapeau a régné sur montréal
pendant près de trente ans pour la
postérité
il a conservé ses bulletins scolaires de
l'école le plateau c'est un excellente
élève d'un ex adapter ce qu'on sent
c'est quelqu'un d'impliqué aussi dès son
arrivée à l'hôtel de ville jean drapeau
se renseigner sur tout ce qui se passe à
montréal sur l'émeute du forum de 1955
survenue après la suspension de maurice
richard
il avait un dossier sur le président de
la ligue nationale de hockey et même
monsieur drapeau comme un collecteur
d'informations il y avait ramassé de
l'information sur clarence campbell donc
comme un espèce de deux qui étaient
quatre ans quand bob qu'est ce qui
affecte l'incident des incidents qui ont
eu lieu un peu partout ça c'est y
raconte un peu d'incidents entre les
messieurs drapeau renseigné monsieur
drapeau se renseignait beaucoup
universel jo drapeau s'est attaqué aux
gros projet dès son deuxième mandat dans
ses archives
on voit bien que pour l'expo 67 il a
voulu déménager pièce par pièce
la tour eiffel de paris à montréal est
tel qu'on le voit sur ce dessin il a
aussi voulu faire construire une grande
tour il ya des études qui ont été faites
et quand ils ont voulu lancer les
soumissions sont rendus compte que les
soumissions était trop élevé donc ils
ont été obligés d'abandonner ce projet
nord monsieur drapeau oui c'est un homme
de projet après l'expo 67
monsieur le maire n'a pas ménagé ses
efforts pour obtenir les jeux olympiques
il ya des informations sur chacun des
délégués donc on voit bon intel
m c'est donc c'est un peu comme ça il
faut qu'on fonctionner
on sait comment le cio fonctionne mais à
cette époque là c'était exactement soit
fallait convaincre jean drapeau avait
été sévèrement blâmé par le rapport
malouf en 1980 pour le dépassement
important des coûts des jeux écorché par
les critiques le maire avait préparé un
document inédit de 300 pages qui devait
servir de réponse à ce rapport qu'il
avait longuement étudié il y aura noté
le rapport madoff et la dernière page où
il dit l'avenir jugera après ça le
présent et déjà déjà jugé et l'avenir
jugera aussi très sévèrement le rapport
de la commission ce n'est pas rien
qu'une réponse à madoff
vingt ans après sa mort les archives de
jean drapeau peuvent dorénavant être
consulté en partie sur internet où ce
rendez vous aux archives de montréal ici
louis fait depuis mai radio canada
montréal